[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
bin zu langsam richtung silvester geht
dann wünscht ihr euch von mir meistens
traub wieder rezepte also rezepte die
man super vorbereiten kann und mit denen
man dann ganz viele menschen auf einmal
satt bekommt und ich glaube dieses
rezept ist so ein kraut feder rezept ich
habe hier nämlich einen hefezopf einen
herzhaften mit einer selbst gemachten
kräuterbutter und im innern habe ich
dann noch so ein fleischmesser wie eine
art polonaise und das kann man dann
wirklich super aus der hand essen also
nicht so direkt auf der hand blutig
besteck dazu aber man kann es eben super
zubereiten auch zu einer silvesterparty
zum beispiel mitnehmen und dann wirklich
ganz vielen menschen servieren
ich werde zuerst einmal den hefeteig
zubereitet wird im hefeteig verwende ich
einen würfel hefe 300 milliliter warmes
wasser zwei teelöffel zucker 200
milliliter milch zwei teelöffel salz und
etwas pfeffer zwei teelöffel chili 2
eigelbe 200 milliliter olivenöl und ein
kilo mehl peter nebe teig gebe ich jetzt
erst die hilfe in eine rührschüssel die
zerkleinerten ein bisschen hier verteilt
haben wir jetzt nicht schon oft zusammen
gemacht dann der zucker rein und das
warme wasser kann ich es ganz kurz
verrühren
[Musik]
dann kommt hier die milch mit rein etwas
pfeffer für den geschmack chili und im
prinzip alle restlichen zutaten die
eigelbe und ich nehme jetzt hier eigelbe
mit rein und auch milch damit der teig
einfach so ein bisschen luftig lockere
wert also das ist nicht anders als einen
pizzateig beim pizzateig verwende ich ja
nur wasser und keine milch und auch
keine eier
und so wird der teig aber so ein
bisschen kuchen ähnlicher öl dazu salz
und aus mehl und dann kann ich den
hefeteig in etwa 5 bis 10 minuten zu
einem geschmeidigen teig
[Musik]
einfach auf stufe 2 und hier gebe ich
noch ein bisschen temperatur tag könnt
ihr auch machen wenn ihr möchtet und
dann einfach schön geschmeidig verkneten
lassen wenn der teig sich nur nicht vom
schüssel rand lösen könnt ihr nochmal
ein bis zwei esslöffel mehl zufügen
also er sollte nicht so fest sein aber
auch nicht zu weit ich will ihn ja
später formen
jetzt ist optimal und ist auch schon
richtig schön warm das heißt der teig
wird auch gleich super schnell auf gehen
einfach kurz zu einer kugel formen und
ich finde da hat auch eine richtig
schöne frage durch die getrocknet und
chilis das habe ich hier noch ein paar
tropfen öl übrig die gebe ich hier in
die schüssel kann den teils reinlegen
und so ein bisschen mich in öl benetzen
und dann abgedeckt wird wo eine stunde
aufgehen lassen
und in der zwischenzeit werde ich schon
mal die hackfleisch bildung machen und
auch die korrupte
[Musik]
die kräuterbutter verwende ich 150 gramm
weiche butter eine knoblauchzehe etwas
salz und pfeffer und hier habe ich noch
die kräuter ich nehme schnittlauch
petersilie rosmarin und minze ich der
kleine jetzt zuerst die knoblauchzehe
die habe ich bereits geschält
hier kommen jetzt die kräuter dazu rein
und da könnte jetzt echt alle kräuter
nehmen die ihr gerne habt die filme
schnittlauch immer sehr aromatisch
basile passt super ins es immer
hervorragend großmann den natürlich auch
so er war alles so grob zerkleinern und
da rein nach rosmarin sich aber ein
bisschen ab
[Musik]
sony spricht da einfach noch die weiche
butter 1
und dann noch salz und pfeffer und das
war es schon und ihr könnt die auch echt
super auf vorrat herstellen und dann
einfriert und habe dann immer selbst
gemachte kräuterbutter
[Musik]
die kräuterbutter ist bereit und jetzt
bereite ich noch schnell die hackfleisch
kühlung so wird die soße verwende ich
ein kilo hackfleisch vom rind 50
milliliter olivenöl eine zwiebel 2
knoblauchzehen 200 gramm tomatenmark
etwas salz und pfeffer hier habe ich
noch zimt chili eine prise zucker etwas
oregano und frischen rosmarin eine dose
tomaten stücke etwas schokolade und
wasser hält das olivenöl in einem großen
topf erhitzen und da gebe ich das gleich
das hackfleisch reihen und berater ist
grünlich an
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
schon mal die zwiebel schneiden und die
knoblauchzehe zerkleinern
[Musik]
gebe ich hier noch die zwiebeln dazu und
brate sie dann etwa drei bis vier
minuten mit an
[Musik]
kommt hier das tomatenmark rein dann die
tomaten aus der dose spiele ich dann
noch aus mit dem wasser hier könnte auch
zum beispiel rotwein nehmen
gemüsebrühe können sie natürlich auch
benutzen
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr hier gerne noch ein
bisschen mehr flüssigkeit zufügen oder
das ganze dann einfach bei niedriger
stufe köcheln lassen
ich gebe es hier noch die gewürze und
die schokolade dazu salz und pfeffer und
kann's abschmecken und dann bei ganz
geringer hitze köcheln lassen und in der
zeit kann ich mich schon mal um den
hefezopf kümmern
kann ich ein bisschen mehr auf die
arbeitsfläche geben
da kommt jetzt der teig drauf
eine große portion jetzt auf der
bemehlten arbeitsfläche zu einem großen
rechteck ausrollen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier die kräuterbutter drauf
jetzt schön gleichmäßig verteilen am
besten mit einer winkel palette
[Musik]
das speicher nicht wenn ihr jetzt noch
kein appetit bekommen auf weiß ich auch
nur dann stimmt was mit natur so jetzt
könnt ihr entweder daraus einen großen
topf auf rollen und praktisch wie beim
hefezopf wie beim ustorf in der mitte
aufschneiden und einmal darum herum
zwiebeln oder ihr macht so wie ich mach
jetzt drei teile und werde diese dann
flechten und ich habe jetzt hier
dieses blech also ist ein ziemlich
großes blech und da möchte ich den job
dann einmal außen rum legen und daher
sollten die strenge lang sein also werde
ich sitzt hier dritteln
und jetzt hier aufräumen
[Musik]
ich gebe es hier noch ein bisschen mehr
drauf damit nicht klebt beim flechten
und ich habe das ziel bringt direkt auf
der arbeitsplatte geschnitten ich habe
aber auch eine stein arbeitsplatte und
die hält alles auf als er jetzt eine
arbeitsplatte habt ihr empfindlich ist
dann solltet ihr natürlich ein
schneidebrett darunter liegen dann bitte
nicht schneiden nehme ich meine form und
werten mit back trance krieg
[Musik]
das lege ich die strenge vorsichtig
hinein und schlecht sie dann da drinnen
zu einem zopf
[Musik]
wie bei den haaren von außen in die
mitte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und am ende müsste einfach ein bisschen
stücke ein ansatzpunkt stehen hat brand
ein verknüpfungspunkt aber wenn es
später nicht ganz so hübsch ist lege ich
einfach ein paar kräuter drüber so
gefährdet jetzt schon ziemlich gut und
entweder könnt ihr ihn jetzt abdecken
und dann aufgehen lassen noch mal für
eine halbe stunde oder erstellt ihnen
gleich in den kalten backofen und damit
die mitte hier schön frei bleibt nehme
ich jetzt einen gegenstand hier zum
beispiel diesen tortenring besprühte ihn
auch mit back trance bringen und dann
kann ich den hier mitten rein legen und
dann bleibt die mitte frei für die
leckere soße und ihm ist er übrigens ab
und zu mal umrühren damit sie nicht
anbrennen
und ich werde ihn hefezopf wird in den
kalten backofen stecken da kann man dem
nicht während der backofen auf reizt
auch noch aufgehen und dann ist beides
gleichzeitig fertig
ich bin jetzt hier sogar mit wachsen
nach dem backen kann ich jetzt den ring
entfernen ganz vorsichtig und wer möchte
kann den job jetzt gerne noch mit
flüssiger butter bestreichen
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt in die mitte die
hackfleisch füllung dann haben wir ein
richtig schönes gericht was ja auch echt
super zu silvester zu bereiten könnte
aber ich habe es gleich noch ein
bisschen abgenommen bevor wir probieren
und bis hin zu heiß wenn es nicht direkt
in den topf 1 geben wollte könnte auch
zum beispiel ein schälchen reinstellen
und können dann im schälchen drin lassen
habe ich sind vor allem voran
[Musik]
jetzt ist der hefezopf wir sind
abgekühlt und ihr dürft probieren
samira hat schon probiert die hat
nämlich einfach die soße genommen und
mit nudeln ich immer cool wenn wir jetzt
auf der baustelle ist mir tun die jungs
gerade die zisterne reinsetzen und ein
riesenloch gebaggert
wir haben richtig humor und das ist
jetzt an silvester gericht morath na ja
wir sind jetzt gerade letztes rezept in
diesem jahr genau und jetzt brauche ich
nur noch einen löffel
man kann das nämlich so dazu und ich
denke dass er schon ein cooler kraut
wieder wenn es jetzt gleich sehen
dann drehen sie durch kann ich mich
nicht mit der hand gehabt das
hackfleisch vielleicht nicht aber das
ist so richtig rot war
ich habe ganz trägerin ist ja auch ganz
dringend außer es wird nicht jetzt vom
ding vor die wehren aus lingen
ich finde man hätte drei machen kann
[Musik]
hammer ist gott wirklich protest werde
gerächt macht es um gegner also wieder
eine baustelle zu hause sagt die leute
werden durch drehen neben seit drei
jahren aber ich muss auch sagen ich hab
jetzt auch wirklich hunger ein ganz
neues gegessen
aber das ist genau sind aufgerufen ihr
könnt das ganze auch vegetarisch machen
wenn ihr sagt hackfleisch ist nicht so
mein ding
dann könnt ihr hier in die mieter
natürlich auch was ganz anderes machen
die kolonne sour cream machen und in die
mitte geben zum reinen dem käse ist was
er möchte lese ich habe auch mal ein
rezept gemacht mit seiner käsemasse in
der mitte könnt ihr euch auch gerne
anschauen und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachbacken das rezept findet
ihr auf sechs minister und sehen uns
wieder ganz bald
aber das war das letzter zeit in diesem
jahr
aber wir machen noch einen abschluss
wieder für ganz ohne spaß hammer
[Musik]